32 und hier setzt das messer ist
komplett drin
herzlich willkommen zu diesem heutigen
video leute ganz kurz bevor das video
los geht es schon mal kurz in der ecke
ein werbevideo der dass videos
unterstützt von der telekom
ich möchte später was zu erzählen aber
legen wir erstmal mit dem normalen video
los was machen wir heute
ich habe diesen fußball hier auf amazon
bestellt da steht drauf one world
project football beziehungsweise
football tbl was ist das nochmal fünf
sprache spanisch erscheinen
der gedanke dahinter ist es gibt ja
überall auf der welt kinder die gerne
fußball spielen aber es gibt halt auch
leider ärmere länder auf der welt wo
vielleicht ein fußball plötzlich eine
sache ist die sich nicht jeder leisten
kann und da fußbälle dann auch noch
kaputt gehen hat sich das wort play
project gedacht wir machen einen fußball
der nicht zerstörbar ist bei diesem
fußball wenn ich mal richtig drauf
drücke die luft geht raus und er pustet
sich einfach von selbst wieder auf das
heißt dieser fußball behauptet dass er
unzerstörbar ist also wahrscheinlich er
seine macher jetzt auch zu mir gesagt du
kannst über bremen aber ja leute das
werden wir heute testen wir gehen mal
raus in den garten gucken erst mal wer
sich so verhält wie normaler fußball ist
und dann messer auto aber selbst der
presse man sagen eine reißzwecke schere
messer und dann auto bestimmten immerhin
schauen wir also ja leute erst mal den
ganz normalen dort testen denn fußball
gut dort zwar fliegt er auch in der
regel gut wir testen lassen so aus
schulterhöhe fallen
ich würde sagen vielleicht ein bisschen
weniger als normaler fußball aber
trotzdem gut das ist jetzt nicht
irgendwie wie so eine software oder so
gesehen meine fußball skills gleichen
den eines cristiano ronaldo das hat ja
leute ich probiere mal ein bisschen hoch
zu halten wenn ich zwei mal hinkriegen
dann bist du gegen mich jetzt mal ein
bisschen fest der weine das heißt man
dann ja okay ich kann es auch wenn ich
will aber ich will gerade nicht das war
ein besonders guter mut es ist derweilen
geburtstermin ist platten oder schwarze
immer noch ganz einfach ins gebüsch
geworden immer noch ganz der aber auf
erden
szenario wohl geht dabei kaputt kommt
mit leute hat gesehen was komplett mit
dem beispiel auch grase kenia
ich glaube der häufigste fall sagt mir
den ball irgendwie einfach im gebüsch
schießt dann senatoren gewonnen geht in
das leder reihen der preis kaputt ich
habe mir mal ein bisschen was
vorbereitet was auch teilweise ein
bisschen extremer ist also passiert zum
beispiel kommt wahrscheinlich in der
regel nicht zum einsatz bei einem
normalen bei dem aber erstmal die
reißzwecken die symbolisiert jetzt quasi
die dornen von einem busch und wir
drücken die einfach mal hier rein
die geht gut durch also es ist nicht so
als würde das einfach nicht
funktionieren die dort steckt jetzt im
ball drin wenn ich sie jetzt raus ziehe
dann müsste der ball eigentlich luft
verlieren oder man schlecht ja ich habe
keine ahnung wo es funktioniert 3 2 1
ich halte direkt das mikrofon nichts
nicht normaler fußball wird jetzt
zwischen die noch was man überall will
die luft raus kommen aber hier passiert
gar nichts
das schon richtig cool eigentlich als
nächstes ein szenario das wird sich auch
jeder von euch kennt man geht so raus
und dann steht für sich jemand da der
mit einem hammer auf den fußball zu
justieren und wieder heute morgen was
bei dir auch lachen like naja das heißt
321 friedrich sowie glaube ich okay das
hat keinen sinn der absorbiert einfach
die schlegel und da passiert überhaupt
nichts würden immer noch mal einfach
daraus passieren ein exot allen kriegen
ja in der regel nicht nur besser war und
das war er
alibi test schraubenzieher ich bin mir
echt nicht sicher das ist wenn er kaputt
geht und ich komme schon gar nicht rein
alter schwede habt habt ihr es gesehen
ich mach's nochmal ich bin drin ich bin
drin
es kommt nichts raus es kommt einfach
keine luft raus guckt euch an
ich nehme den schraubenzieher und habe
mit mama durch
ich habe gar eingehämmert der
schraubenzieher steckt und wenn ich
ihnen jetzt raus ziehe ich jetzt noch
mal ins mikrofon
da ist das loch ins mikrofon damit
rücken zusammen
das ist irgendwie wichtigste ist bei der
wehr pustet sie einfach selbst wieder
auf über wie funktioniert das
aber apple music ist ein gutes stichwort
magst was braucht man um mehr verwenden
datenvolumen aber dazu kommen wir gleich
er kennt es nicht man steht mit seinem
fußball plötzlich kommen freut sie zu
komplett messer durch verein fußball
passiert einfach nichts
[Musik]
das ist volle kraft also wirklich voll
kraft voraus matrosen und wir schauen
uns das an
der ist der held auch einfach viel aus
bei einem anderen fußball hättest du
schon durchgeschnitten ich wette ich
wette was man als nächstes machen säge
oder auto
die werke probierst die see geehrt und
dann hast du deine leute einfach
abstimmen ob du das messer reinsch text
oder mit dem auto drüber für das messer
nicht ganz selbstlos geht wieder raus
aber nächsten geht es okay segel richtig
dass der junge juni das so leute das
sägeblatt ist schon fast komplett
verschwunden da drin
ich bin wirklich mit voller kraft dabei
aber es passiert nichts
wir brauchen auf jeden fall drastischere
mittel ich muss glaube ich statt quer
entweder reinheit oder mit dem auto
drüber fahren
das messer hier ist ein auto ich klicke
jetzt mal auch live video starten
seht hier oben in der ecke lte das heißt
ich habe kein wlan aber wer jetzt
vielleicht trotzdem den instagram
livestream starten und normalerweise
wäre das jetzt vor der stress weil man
immer nur 500 megabyte im monat an
datenvolumen hat und dann wäre so ein
livestream und zack kann man nur noch
fünf tage surfen punkt genau darum geht
es bei der sache die ich euch auch
erzählen wollte und zwar kann man bei
der telekom wenn man bereits
festnetzkunde ist drei monate lang
unbegrenztes datenvolumen bekommen das
heißt ihr könnt wirklich alles im
internet machen ihr könnt euch auf den
weg zur schule alle sieben harry potter
teile runterladen oder keine ahnung
komplett wikipedia unter laden alles
ohne beschränkungen über all das ist
richtig cool ich selbst kann das schon
nutzen lässt dann würd ich sagen starten
einfach mal den livestream ich brauche
eure hilfe
und zwar habe ich diesen fußball hier
der fußball soll angeblich unzerstörbar
sein wie soll ich probieren ihn kaputt
zu machen soll ich probieren einen messi
fußball einzustecken
oder soll ich mit einem auto drüber
fahren ich warte jetzt mal kurz die
antworten im chat ab also gerade
schreibt jeder messer messer messer okay
leute alle schreiben messer das heißt
wir probieren es erst mal mit dem messer
und dann mit dem auto dankeschön für
eure entscheidungshilfe wir sehen uns
dann besser ist es geworden ich hätte
eigentlich auf auto getippt aber darum
geht es eben solche sachen und viele
andere sachen kann man einfach machen
wenn man keine probleme mit datenvolumen
hat uns soviel verwenden kann wie man
möchte
deshalb wenn ihr mehr darüber wissen
wollt schickt unten den link in der
beschreibung ab drei monate lang
kostenloses unbegrenztes datenvolumen
abstauben deshalb schaut vorbei ich
würde sagen wir machen jetzt den test
ich würde sagen leute seid ihr bereit
drei mal die klinge von mir weg 2 und
das ist voller kraft okay das messer
steckt richtig tief drin jetzt schon der
hier setzt das messer ist komplett drin
jo halt dein maul ich kriege sie auch
wieder raus aber in diesem fall steckt
ein messer wenn ich das messer jetzt
ausziehen und er keine luft verliert da
bin ich richtig geflasht man ja denken
point of sale neben dem messer sind
schon so lächeln kann nicht mehr ganz
halten
und mal ganz kurz das messer nehmen wir
bei doch besser bei der trend guck mal
leute es war ungefähr
und darum war noch rein kommt man der
anderen sonderteil ein messer war in
diesem ball drin aber ganz darin
versenkt so viele leute wir brauchen das
auto
wir testen einfach noch mal funktioniert
der fußball noch kann es dir vorstellen
kann ja sein dass wenn man so drauf
tritt und so dass da die luft raus kommt
aber leute das auto muss her okay leute
ich platze jetzt dabei häufig passiert
dem auto nix und legt ihn hierhin nicht
platzt dinge auch so was ist denn jetzt
wieder ein bisschen runter das auch
wirklich verhält nicht das selber
wegrutscht musste sich natürlich wieder
auf na klar
ich sollte meine augen schützen
ja
diese wirklich bereit mal
okay leute
[Musik]
guckt euch das an ich stehe mit dem auto
auf dem bau und der ist gerade so was
vom platz der ist sowas von platts
platts in schlumpf ich werde jetzt
wieder nach vorne fahren wenn er weiter
das überlebt
ein auto drauf ich bin ich finde das
super gefahren und er pustet sich selbst
wieder auf ok wir sind wieder im garten
und ihr seht es nichts gefälscht das ist
der gleiche walde gerade unter dem auto
war
wir probieren es damit zu spielen leute
in dieser ball nicht unzerstörbar ist
was dann das hat ein messer eingesteckt
drübergefahren dem hammer drauf gehauen
da waren schraubenschlüssel drin und er
ist einfach immer noch gefüllt